we're following good news from Saint
Mary's Hospital in London the Duchess of
Cambridge has just given birth to her
third child and it's a boy eight pounds
seven ounces that's a good size Prince
William of course was present for the
birth of his son both mother and baby
are doing very well we're told this
royal birth comes ahead of the upcoming
wedding between Prince Harry and Megan
Markell the photographer who snapped
this engagement photo will be back
behind the lens for the wedding
we met alexei limber ski before he was
officially asked to document the May
19th nuptials he told us about getting
the call he never expected let's go back
to you pick up the phone they say it's
Kensington Palace calling had you had
any dealings with Kensington Palace were
you thinking why are they calling me
that was probably affair I mean you
would had no dealings with Kensington so
how did they even know to call you I
have no idea a mutual friend suggested
Prince Harry and Megan Markel check out
alexei Luber Mary's Instagram yes
beautiful a thing where the fashion
photographer post his work with some of
the world's most famous faces you've
shot Angelina Jolie shot Julia Roberts
you come with a lot of credibility and
you're very good at what you do Thank
You Luba Mirsky who lives in New York
City was in London at the time visiting
his mother who was undergoing surgery
the operation was a success and so was
his hastily arranged meeting with the
newly engaged and soon-to-be royal
couple it was very wonderful to get that
instantaneous read on them because you
know love is when you see young love or
any-any love when it's in its genesis
stage it's the most beautiful thing to
see I love love Luba Mirsky sometimes
works in the small South African nation
of Botswana that's where he was raised
great the country is a favorite getaway
for Prince Harry and the place he took
Megan Markel on their very first
vacation yeah gorgeous and like Harry
the photographer is also a prince tell
us how you're a prince my father is a
Polish Prince
and I was told about it when I was 11
his mom confirmed the news adding he had
the title but little else she very
quickly doused my flames of excitement
by saying this and there's no more
there's no more land is no more palaces
castles which is you just have a name
yeah so very naively I said to her what
what's the point of title and she said
this phrase to me which has stuck with
me forever and I always thank my mother
for this she said if you want to be a
prince in today's world you have to be a
prince in your heart and in your actions
the actions of his serene Highness yep
that's his actual title include working
to improve the lives of the impoverished
as an ambassador for the charity
concerned worldwide it's a dedication to
philanthropy shared by Prince Harry and
Megan Markel who he first photographed
at Windsor Castle for their official
engagement photos now this was my
favorite I do think that there's such a
tender intimacy here her eyes are closed
and he's clearly looking at her do you
remember what happened in this moment it
was just a beautiful that was the last
shot of the day you know I got this big
overcoat on and I said just just wrap
her up and I think she turned around to
him and there was this beautiful moment
and they were just they were hugging and
looking at each other and smiling but
you know what I like about it Alexei I
feel like we were capturing a moment
between the two of them I feel like we
captured a real intimate quick moment
into their lives what were your
impressions of them both just lovely
young normal people you know just normal
yeah yeah I believe that yeah they're
just they're very welcoming they're very
gracious you feel listened to when
they're talking to you so really just
good good people Alexei Luber Mayer ski
he's a great guy I think he's very
handsome he's also very talented but
imagine when we talked to him he had not
gotten the Royal assignment to do the
wedding
he had only gotten the engagement
pictures and I said do you think you're
gonna get the job he goes I have no idea
probably not oh I had a very short
interaction with them and then he got
the call a couple of weeks ago so I'm
thrilled for him
we did so well on the first gig yeah
that you bond so quickly they clearly
liked it a great photographer can
capture what someone's really like you
know and I think he did that those and
just like you said those very intimate
moments very well and we'll bring you
live coverage of the Royal Wedding next
month we're going back it's Saturday May
19th starting at 4:00 a.m. Eastern
that's three central right here on CBS